Egg. This is Jad. Before we get started on the podcast, just two things. First,
the MailChimp challenge we did a little while back. Uh, we did it.
You guys did it.
I mean the deal was if a certain number of you became sustaining members,
MailChimp would pitch in with some money. It happened and we're super grateful.
So thank you. We forget did it. Okay. Number two,
I want to let you know that toward the end of this podcast,
it's about to happen. Hey, yeah, we haven't even said it yet. Wait, wait, wait.
We're excited. Yeah, we're happy to be here.
You guys love to hang out until the the end. Is that cool? Why?
Why do we have to be at the end? That was, can we just be up top?
But that was the deal. We talked, this is my rosa parks moment.
I met them in front of this episode.
And you know why we can say that is because we are black. Yeah,
you're putting me in a box. [inaudible].
So what I was gonna say is if we're going to, at the end of this podcast,
we're going to come back and I'm going to introduce you guys listening to two
very funny people who you just heard Phoebe Robinson, Jessica Williams,
they're starting a podcast here at w NYC studios. It's called two dope queens.
It's awesome. We'll talk about it. All right. So you guys all hang out?
Yeah. Alright, cool.
Oh wait, you're listening,
listening to radio lab radio from W N Y s e
Jad Robert Radiolab.
So I'm going to just tell you the story just very briefly.
I'm going to tell you the story of three enormous mysteries,
two of which you know very well,
and one of which I bet you've never heard of ever. Hmm. Okay.
Mystery number one. This is the one I know, or the one that is the one,
you know. All right. So about 4 billion years ago,
the earth is one huge,
mostly ocean of lifeless chemicals. [inaudible]. And then for some reason,
which we have never really been able to understand lifeless chemicals,
suddenly Printemps a pulse and you get life.
Hello? Yes, I have just arrived now. Hey, wonderful. Like nick for example,
Nick Lane. I am a professor of evolutionary biochemistry,
a University College in London. Nick
is the main guy in the story I'm about to tell you,
but just to continue this set up, that was mystery number one.
Where does life come from next?
Mystery number three to make it more interesting. What about the two?
Two is going to be the subject of the stories and more important.
The middle blend is the deep surprise because you've never heard of it,
so I thought I would skip over to to remind you how familiar you are with one in
three fine, go to three and then come back to t three. All right.
Consciousness. For some reason, for some reason,
one animal on the planet and only one that we can notice seems to spring into
this very elaborate sense of self awareness. We don't know why it happened.
We don't know how it happened. It just right.
I'm familiar with one and three. You are now. Here's number two.
That's the one that keeps nick up at night. Yeah. Because those are kind of a,
a gap,
a black hole where everything important in biology happened and we have very
little insight into what, what it was black hole and biology. I like that.
So you want to know what it is? This black hole? Yes you do.
You do. You know you do. Okay. Yes. Mystery number two,
pay. We're a little bit past one way before three,
4 billion years ago. We got life. It's just floating around, you know,
little specks in the ocean, you know, very simple cells.
Probably pretty much like a a bacterium as we know them today.
This is very small for a start.
If you're looking at the period at the end of a sentence,
say is it about that size or smaller than a much smaller,
much smaller than that. A couple of thousandths of a millimeter long.
So tiny, tiny things.
They all look the same in the size and shape and they don't seem to be doing
anything. Very interesting. Well, you know,
they were having babies and they were using energy and they were feeling a lot
of things out. But if you look inside one of these little things,
not much going on. S inspiration, eat is often described as a bag of chemicals.
They're not complex, they're not complex, simple, simple as can be,
and it goes on like this for millions of years and then tens of millions of
years and hundreds of millions of years. Well, really 2 billion years or so,
2 billion years if not longer. You just have tiny, tiny, simple,
tiny, simple popping, bopping, sitting, drifting in the water, bopping, bopping,
pupping, bopping, nothing. Nothing, nothing. No. Come on. No, I look,
I'm telling you this for us for a good reason. There is,
you should know there is no rule which says life has to get bigger.
We could've stayed infinitely small, 400 billion years,
you know, forever. Really? Really? Yes, really. But then Chad,
something happened
as they say about 2 billion years ago. All of a sudden, practically overnight,
a new kind of life shows up a new sound and it's
a lot bigger than what was before. And these first ones, the,
the actual volume went out around about 10,000 times bigger. Well,
massive increase in size. It's like we just jumped from specs
to battle ships and inside these massive pieces of complex machinery and it
becomes bigger and bigger and more complex.
And it ultimately leads to jellyfish giant redwood trees,
Beluga whales, Beluga Caviar, which is baby whale.
It's not [inaudible]. Well, nevermind Sherri. Trees hurdles.
Librarians are range
chillers, orangutans, elephants, teradeck titles. There's your second mystery.
Like how did life for such an enormously long time say so simple,
so dull and so tiny, and then boom,
you get these big life forms like what happened and why did it not happen for
such a long time?
Hmm.
Well, are you going to enlighten me with some attempts at answers? Yes,
but I want to remind you, this is a few that we've got here. Just, you know,
we're making an hypothesis. I mean, who,
who knows really exactly what happens. I mean, we're never going to get,
we're never gonna find like found footage of that moment, right? We can,
we can only imagine and we can only use the evidence that we've got now.
That is ed young. I'm a science writer. At the Atlantic.
It's the guy who introduced me to nick or Nick's work and this theory,
and he says, here's the important thing to know. I mean,
I think during those 2 billion years when nothing much happened,
it wasn't that life didn't get complicated.
It's the life couldn't get complicated. There is a barrier.
There is an energetic canyon that simple cells find themselves trapped in
what it means. It's, it's a huge deal to try to get big.
Think about what it takes to get bigger or it takes bigger soul balls.
It takes more surface, more openings, let things in, push things out,
more power, more moving parts,
and then they make the whole thing fit and work together.
You got to have a bigger design planets, your DNA,
so you're going to need more DNA and all that DNA needs to be copied.
You're gonna need some DNA copiers.
You then need to read the information that's encoded within it,
some DNA meters and you need to use that information to build protein and some
builders and that last bit is especially costly. In other words,
you don't get bigger for free. Every new step takes extra energy.
Just like if you're going to, um, you know,
if you're going to increase the size of your company by a thousand times,
if you're going to have a thousand times more employees,
you're going to need to pay them all. Where are you going to get the money?
I mean, you and I, we might be able to go to a bank,
but if you're a teeny little thing, you don't have any place to go.
So how do you get bigger? I mean,
can't you just eat more food than you normally eat so that you get more energy
so that slowly over time you get bigger? No, no. I mean, well,
you could do that, but suppose you don't have the stomach to absorb the food.
Uh, you make a stomach somehow way, I don't know. In order to make the stomach,
you gotta eat more food to build a stomach, but in order to eat more food,
you gotta have the stomach.
But you can't really have the stomach unless you eat the food and you can't eat
the food. And that you have the stomach, you're stuck in a whole kind of,
it's like a, it's a catch 22 kind of a thing.
You're stuck in what Ed Calls Er in Energetic Canyon and to climb over the walls
of that canyon and to start experimenting with complexity,
you need something improbable to happen. You need something very special,
so special and so improbable that according to theory,
over the course of all of our planet's history,
that has only happened successfully once. What? What happened? Well,
here's the theory,
here's life bopping along and it's boring, boring, boring way.
Everything is very tiny, very simple. And then one day,
two single celled creatures start
drift towards one another.
One of them is an Oken little blob and one of them is a bacteria,
another little blob, but smaller.
They belonged to the two great houses of simple things in the Montague's and
Capulets of 2 billion BC. Anyways,
these two little cells start to get near each other slowly.
Yeah. What each cell wants is what the other one has to offer.
Nikki imagines that, I don't know,
maybe the little one was expelling some kind of chemical. Let,
let's say some something like hydrogen gas, just for the sake of an argument.
Let's say the big one likes hydrogen.
That's what he wants and maybe the big one spits out nitrogen,
which is what the little one wants.
So they kind of come together and they snuggle up.
Totally ordinary thing. It happens all the time with cells, he said,
but in this case,
that snuggling gets closer and closer until somehow those two cells meet and
they merge. They just squished together. How did they merge? Uh, you know,
membranes, fuse cell walls don't always form. Maybe the big,
when it had a hole in its wall and a little one just fell through the hole.
I don't really know what the mechanism is, but we do know as possible.
The point is somehow this little guy gets in,
the bacterium finds itself inside the Arcane.
So that's the first thing that happens. One little guy gets inside,
another little guy. Okay,
I got to tell you, this is, this is, this is extremely rare. For the most part,
sells don't get inside other cells and when they do get inside of the cells,
for the most part, it doesn't work out.
Because if you're this little guy on the inside and now you're trapped,
you can't get to the things you want to eat.
It's cutoff from the outside world and chances are
it will die, which is what happens. You know,
99.999% of the time,
but not this time.
If, if the, if the swallower is capable of,
of bringing in that outside world and feeding it, spoon feeding it to us,
swallow he, if you like, then then it will work.
And maybe that's what happened here. Says an equity,
maybe the big sell had some kind of mutation that allowed it to keep feeding the
little cell in its belly.
So the little self survives and thrives because the second thing that happens
here is the little cell of the inside starts to devise.
So now you have, you know,
a cell with two cells inside it and maybe then four cells inside it,
which if you're a big cell, it's normally not a great situation.
You find yourself with weak guests inside.
You imagine having a house party in [inaudible],
the guests won't go away damning into cost among themselves. If you like.
I'm producing more guests.
There's going to be a riot and that was going to be a mudder or something.
The point is says neck. When you get to this point, it really shouldn't work,
but somehow it did. Like not only did one cell get in another,
which is rare,
and then that so survive even rare and then divided without creating a riot.
Even rare,
but then somehow this big cell finds ways over and over taking care of holes,
little new house guests
and they, they're, they're, they're all stages of their life cycle.
You've got some old folk in there and you've got some babies in there and how
are you going to do it? Well, you'll probably need to,
let's put it in a maternity ward. First of all, to look after the babies. Let's,
uh, you know, let's, let's, let's put in some kind of clinic for end of life.
For the, for the, for the geriatrics
sauna. Oh,
this big sell is able to construct all this new machinery inside itself to keep
this extraordinarily various group of house guests happy. Wait,
why, why would it bother? I mean like what is the, I mean,
what is the sell get in return? And you,
you said that it didn't have enough energy to build itself bigger.
So how is it even doing this? Well now,
now you're getting to the real nub of the story.
The key here says nick is those little house guests.
They're living now in the big sale. Yeah. They're not ordinary house guests.
They are a very specific kind of bacteria that we now call Mitochondria.
And if you look at the descendants of those little guys who live in us right
now,
they have an amazingly strong electrical charge that sort of radiates across the
membrane on their outside.
And that electrical charge is, you know, it's, it's tiny.
It's a 150 millivolts. Um,
but if you shrink yourself down to the size of a molecule,
uh, and feel the strength of the electric field right next to that membrane,
it's actually 30 million volts per meter, which is equivalent to a,
a bolt of lightning. Whoa.
This is what the big sale gets back because it's return gift
[inaudible]
and it's this new electricity that gets it,
that helps it fund all these new adventures and construction projects.
Now they can support enormously larger genomes.
So you can have where bacteria may have one or two copies of a gene,
you can now have pinboard genes or 20 or 30 or maybe 50.
There's no penalty for doing so.
And what and what that gives you as a [inaudible]
I never redundancy that allows different genes to do slightly different jobs or
too diverged to, you know, you've got the scope to experiment to try things out.
So you have one group going
off to become algae and plants and another group becoming animals and another
group becoming the funky and so on. The, the, the descendants did so well.
They've taken over the world and they all came from that one single coming
together. That one union. Yes.
It comes down to one merger between two cells that made one cell and then
everything comes from that
[inaudible]
you mean the redwood tree or the hummingbird?
A fungus piece of algae growing in a pond.
Every type form of life that we can see with our naked eyes and many that we
can't come from that single cell
[inaudible]
and what the spawns says nick is.
This is how we get the great tree of life that we see all around us after eons
and eons of Sameness.
Suddenly we get this many splendor thing that is nature and it starts right
here. What we're looking at is truly the second genesis.
Wait. Okay. Hold on a second. Hold on. Hold on.
How do we know any of this actually happened? Like all the,
that all of the life that we can see comes from one cell.
How would we possibly know that? Well,
I'm starting with us through the same ones in in, if you,
if you go in and look at the genetic material inside our cells,
about half of our genes, a little bit less than half. Um,
we find them in bacteria or Okeh Nixon.
As you can see very clearly that the original DNA of those two cells,
those two cells that merged into one, they're insiders,
so there's the sequence and their structure has remained kind of almost intact
for 2 billion years and just the structure of your cells alone provides an
important clue. If you look at the sales of all of those things,
if you look at it,
if I take one of your cells and one cell from that fungus or from the spruce or
from the whale, unless you were a, unless you were an expert,
unless you've been trained in this stuff,
it will be very hard to tell the difference between those. In other words,
all of ourselves, and this is across animals, plants, fungi,
they all look something like those original cells, very, very similar.
They will have that nucleus, that internal skeleton,
they would have mitochondria. Those are the lightening bolts,
the descendants of that first little guy that got swallowed. You know,
we have 40 trillion cells and each of those has got,
let's say on average a thousand Mitochondria. So that,
that's a tremendous number of mitochondria in one human being.
And the giant redwood tree has a lot more than that. And so does the worm.
And so from that point of view, just biomass,
we are about 40% mitochondria. So just from biomass,
they are possibly the single most, um,
prolific lifeform that ever existed. Okay. You got me.
I do like this idea of like trillions of little lightning bolts in your belly.
I mean, it is also like, you know, it's a little bit like, it's our producer,
Soren Wheeler,
who, who chimed in as we were working on this. You remember our guy,
what was his name from the floppy ears?
The kind of Richard Wrangham is that rich Richard Wrangham? Yeah.
Consists of finding energy. That's him.
He had that thing about, he wrote a book as all a long time ago,
but it was all about a, actually talked to him at the time.
Human ancestors are going along doing their thing and they're eating raw leaves
in the forest. Same way that chimps do now. But then once they learned to cook,
once you start cooking,
those are terrific advantaged cooking would break things down and then once the,
then you don't have to break things down inside you,
which means that you're putting less energy into your food but getting more out
of it,
maybe it increases the amount of energy that you can get from your food by 25 30
40 50% maybe more.
And his theory is that that that is when we got smart because we were in again
an energy canyon where there was just given what was around you and how much
work it took to break it down to the parts that you need.
You couldn't do much until you light a fire underneath it and you like a
lightning bolt and you break it down so that you don't have to do that work.
Cause now the fire's doing that work,
then you put it in your tummy and you get all the goods with half the work and
now,
now you have time and energy to make a brain that can think about it about
itself.
That is when the genus homo humans in the first full flowering of the sense of
that word emerged. Wow, that's interesting.
So the Energy Canyon leaping theory might actually touch on mystery number 32
the consciousness one. Yeah,
but don't you think that cooking is an act that's intentional? I mean I,
you know, when you decide to light the fire and cook the meat,
then you're doing something that you intend to do,
but really gets to me is when you go back to the original pairing,
I mean that was just pure accident and that so much would flow from something
completely cosmically accidental. That's the,
that's what would really,
really kind of freaks me out actually.
That merger and the, the,
the harmonious continuance of that merger was so breathtakingly improbable that
only once did it take,
nick says it only happened once 2 billion years ago.
And there's no evidence to suggest that it has happened since.
So there is no trajectory towards necessary complex life for universe is not
pregnant with the idea of us.
There's nothing about the way that evolution has worked on earth to suggest that
complex life is in an inevitable outcome. And if this hadn't happened,
would the earth just be still rich with, with little, I don't know,
life forms that are smaller than a, than a grain of rice?
That's all we'd ever get. I think that's the idea.
Does that mean that you have to have this incident on planet Zan Tar and planet
Xanterra 36 and planted Zane? That's, that's really interesting, right?
So I think, um, when we think about finding the prospect to finding alien life,
we think the universe,
the universe is so vast that we cannot be alone,
that there must be life on other worlds.
But I think what this tells us is that we will probably find life elsewhere,
but it will probably be microbial. Um, it w you know, the,
the odds of the odds of finding something that you know,
like the aliens that you would, you would expect, right. So the,
the odds of finding your Stolz Cantina are significantly reduced.
The odds of finding like a bacterium somewhere probably reasonable.
Okay.
You might find life. Um, but maybe it's going to be boring.
We can leave it right there.
Um, but you know, you probably won't get killed by them over, so that's,
that's a good thing. That's true.
Yeah.
Nick Lane's book on this theory is called the vital question.
Special thanks to Eric Steinberg for his work on this podcast and to Richard
Wrangham, whose book is catching fire Ed Young, whose forthcoming book is,
I contain multitudes. You can find all of these references on our website,
radiolab.org and a speaking of Bates. Yes.
This is what this called this soulmates. Yeah. Well,
we as promised you and introduce you to two comedy mates, uh,
after the break. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. Stick around.
Hi, this is Shereen from sunrise, Florida.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation and Hanson public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey guys, this is Alison calling from Luxembourg.
Radiolab is supported by rocket mortgage by quicken loans.
Rocket mortgage brings the mortgage process into the 21st century.
With this completely online process,
safely share your bank statements and pay stubs with the touch of a button.
Ditch the paperwork and use your phone or tablet to get approved for purchase or
refinance in minutes.
Get a custom mortgage solution whenever and wherever you want.
Check out rocket mortgage
today@quickenloansdotcomslashradiolabequalhousinglenderlicensedinallfiftystatesandmlssconsumeraccess.org
number 30 30 alright, the
quill, which Radiolab is supported by Google and Squarespace.
Make your business official with Google and Squarespace.
When you create a custom domain and a beautiful business website with
Squarespace, you'll receive a free year of business,
email and professional tools from Google.
It's the simplest way to look professional online.
Visit squarespace.com/google to start your free trial.
Use the offer code document for 10% off on your first purchase.
Google and Squarespace. Make it professional. Make it beautiful.
Just a heads up. I speak in a, in a breathes a lot,
so I'll just say things like totes and like early taunts and you just have to
roll with this. Go with it. Yeah, I'll nod like I know what you're saying. Okay,
great. Jed here as promised at the top of the show,
I want to introduce you to a new project that comes from uh,
two very funny people.
My name is Phoebe Robinson and I am Michael Fassbender's feature baby Mama.
My name is Jessica Williams and I plan to be the maid of honor and Phoebe and
Michael Fassbender's wedding.
Yay.
You're okay with that? I literally just put myself in your fake wedding.
Obviously you're in the wedding. All right.
So Jessica Williams and Phoebe Robinson are two people who were obsessed with
Michael Fassbender. I don't even think he's that hot now.
That's so controversial. And they are both comedians and writers.
A Phoebe has worked for MTV and Comedy Central, a Jessica Williams,
you might know from the daily show where she's a corresponded and the two of
them you have teamed up to make a podcast called a,
it's debut and today it's called two dope queens. And my bet is it,
if you like Radiolab, you will also like this podcast. Yeah. All right.
Can I be old white for a second? There's nothing else for you to be yeah.
So dope people still use the word dope. Yeah, I think so. Yeah. But you know,
even if they don't like all it takes is like two black people to make something
cool. Yeah. That's the rule.
We came and we walked down the street tomorrow and we had our shoes on the wrong
foot and as long as it's two black people doing mean hello Chris Cross.
When they did the, the jeans, it was just two of them. They were females nation.
How did you guys meet? Uh, we met, uh,
almost two years ago.
I was doing a background on a black hair in the military piece that she was
doing for the daily show story. As Jessica was doing this segment,
Phoebe was part of the segment.
One thing leads to another and Phoebe and Vice Jessica to cohost is comedy,
thinks she was doing like a live thing and she says the moment they got up there
on stage, we murdered homicide.
First degree murder law and order baby. This is all good things,
right? Yeah. Yes, yes. On stage. I was like, this feels really good. She's like,
yeah, and I was like, we should do this more often. And so we're like, oh well,
you know, like kind of like we start dating. You're like, oh yeah,
well we'll go to a movie or like, Oh yeah,
we'll go to the mat and we'll just keep seeing how things go at the end of the
day and then after a while it's,
it morphed into something that is our baby and we made a baby. Yeah.
We made a baby
favorite white lady customer service thing is never in my life.
It is
two dope queens is a live comedy show that happens at Union Hall here in
Brooklyn. Generally what happens is, and Jessica,
they get up on stage and you just kind of riff for a few minutes.
I think if you're in the audience,
we really want it to feel like you're hanging out with us. So they get up there,
they sort of go back and forth for awhile.
Then we have some of our favorite friends who are stand ups come and do sets in
between us talking and hanging out.
I wanted to share this thing that my girlfriend and I have been doing,
like this comedian that Phoebe and I both love and named Gary Goldman. Um,
we've, we role play.
Okay.
The other night we were playing secretary of Housing and Urban Development
[inaudible]
but here's the, here's the twist.
She was secretary of Housing and urban development.
I was deputy secretary of housing urban development. So there was that,
there was that status thing. She was my boss and I,
I didn't feel she was pushing her agenda hard enough. I was like,
did we come to Washington to make friends?
Okay.
We came to make changes.
Okay
then,
then we have people like Michelle Bhutto who's really funny and she does stuff
for comedy central a lot of places.
So here's a clip of comedian Michelle Bhutto, uh,
telling a story about how she met this guy
when I was like, oh my God, this is the one,
like we're going to move in together, we're going to live by the mall.
And he came to visit me in New York one time about the cell phones were on the
bed and they were exactly alike and it rang and I picked it up and this girl was
on the other end. She goes, is Eric there? And I go, who it is?
And she go, who it is? And I go,
who did
[inaudible]
this went on for a real long time.
cause we knew who to call.
This was, okay. So you up the next clip and the the Naomi clip? Yes.
Like who is Naomi? Who is Naomi? EQ. Paragon. She's a younger woman,
but she is practically an old lady.
Like all she wants to do is she says in her standup is like sit at home with a
blanket and play with her cats. As you can imagine. I love to watch procedural.
I love it. Okay. I love me. Criminal minds is my number one.
I do like classic law and order, but I do prefer a special victim, you know?
Yes. I just love it. I love it. I love it. It's,
it's amazing how every episode is involved with white women in peril.
You know? It's like a white woman's in peril. That's how we get people to care,
you know? And it's just nonsense.
But if there's one thing that I feel like we should be taking away,
is it like what ladies? Okay, Megan's. Sarah's. Becky's.
Okay.
You guys have got to stop with the jogging at dawn and dusk.
I hate to go Jesse Jackson, but if the light is low, you should not go.
Are you following me? Are you following me?
If you're jogging at those hours, you got to up shit. Okay?
You're either going to find a dead body or become a dead body.
Stop it with a joking.
You always like to have women represented doing stand up or story telling on our
show. We make sure that that's in every episode and people,
different orientations, people of color, like it's really, really fun. Yeah,
and I, I hope that, like if you come to see the show,
or even if you start listening to our podcast,
that you'll see that we really love doing it. You just want a hilarious show.
Yep. And I think we really do deliver on that. Yeah.
Phoebe Robinson and Jessica Williams from the brand new w NYC studios podcast
two dope queens. Definitely check it out.
Go to iTunes or wherever you get your podcasts from and check them out.
Two Dope Queens. All right. Thank you guys. Thank you. I'm Chad. I boom. Ron,
thanks for listening.